hello i'm nicole schmitz and i'm an
artist
and i also run a foundry
[Music]
today we're making some telescope
mirrors out of bronze
and we're using a traditional sand
molding process
the sand is packed around a pattern this
one is made of cherry wood
it will be very slightly larger than the
finished piece which we're after so this
accounts for the shrinkage of the metal
the sand is packed into a flask which is
the kind of container for the sand
and it's made out of cast iron
so you put the pattern in pack the sand
around it
[Music]
and then open up the two sides of the
mold and carve in
the running system and the running
system is kind of like a plumbing system
inside the mold so a place for the
molten metal to go into the mold and the
gas in the air to be
released out the top so once uh this is
complete
the flask is then put back together and
wired shut
we're using especially alloy block
bronze which is
a high tin bronze to put in these molds
so you get that nice silvery
finish on the mirrors that we're after
so the furnace that we use today
is a kind of replica chimney furnace
this is a kind of furnace that would
have been more common
uh say in the united states during the
industrial revolution so
before the invention of electricity and
the common use of
it inside the furnace you'd use a
crucible so a crucible is set on a grate
inside the furnace and the fire is built
around it
and as that comes up to temperature you
keep adding more fuel to keep
like a big fire around it to to get it
up to temperature
so the other exciting bit of foundry
work obviously is pouring molten metal
[Music]
it looks almost like water it's an
amazing material to see
molten right but actually when you pick
it up in the crucible it's really heavy
you forget
when you look at it exactly how how
heavy this material is
warm metal after it's been poured is
quite fragile so you want to let it cool
thoroughly
and what you're left with is this very
hard silvery metal
that um with very crisp edges that's
going to be used in polish too like a
bright mirror finish so that
you can see through the telescope up
into the heavens i guess
you